Everyone and their mother know about the most
famous superhero couples of all time like
Superman and Lois Lane or Harley Quinn and
The Joker but there are tons of other super
powered relationships that are totally hot.
Whether they haven’t had a chance on the
big screen yet or they have just slipped past
people unnoticed to we are taking a look at
some of the lesser known steamy super couples
in our list of 10 Hot Superhero and Villain
Relationships You Didn't Know About.
Enjoy this video and be sure to hit that subscribe
button for more awesome stuff, every single
day!
Scott Lang and Hope Van Dyne
Ant-Man briefly introduced us to the relationship
between Scott and Hope and from the looks
of it; we are excited to see what comes next.
That being said, their relationship starts
out in pretty awkward way because they do
meet when Scott wakes up with her watching
him sleep.
They then spend most of the film taking jabs
at each other until they finally share that
great kiss at the end of the movie.
In 2018, we will get to see the next Ant-Man
movie, called Ant-Man and The Wasp, which
will feature both Scott and Hope as a superhero
couple that we can only imagine will be very
hot and wildly entertaining.
Aquaman and Mera
The King and Queen of Atlantis may have a
somewhat dysfunctional relationship but there
is no denying that it is fueled by hot passionate
love.
The couple originally bonded over being outcasts
to their people despite holding positions
of great power within their society and they
have always had a magnetic connection in the
comics.
For some reason, Aquaman has often been considered
a lame and soft superhero so we are hoping
that a grittier movie is coming his way and
that it will feature some hot scenes between
him and Mera.
With Jason Mamoa and Amber Heard lined up
to play these roles, we are excited for the
world to get to see Aquaman and Mera on the
big screen in 2018!
Spiderman and Mary Jane (Spiderman 1,2,3)
While this hot couple may seem very obvious
to some, we will need to mention it as we
can guarantee that there are people who have
only seen The Amazing Spiderman series that
pairs Peter Parker with Gwen Stacy.
While that relationship was okay, it definitely
doesn’t measure up to the more raw and passionate
couple of Spidey and Mary Jane.
In the comics and in the Toby Maguire Spiderman
movies this couple was at the center of the
action and had some pretty steamy scenes.
For years, the famous upside down alleyway
kiss has been copied and referenced and that
is the most sincere form of admiration.
Mary Jane will be coming back in Spiderman
Homecoming and we imagine it will be awesome!
Sara Lance and Nyssa Al Ghul
In the DC TV show Arrow, Sara Nance finds
herself on the brink of starvation when Nyssa
Al Ghul, the daughter of Ra’s Al Ghul, saved
her.
Sara then began to train with Nyssa to become
part of the league and during this process
she and Nyssa also started an intimate and
very hot relationship.
Unfortunately, their relationship was as complicated
as it was steamy due to Nyssa’s father being
a crime king.
Even after they parted ways, Sara and Nyssa
still have love for each other and are willing
to put themselves at serious risk in the name
of protecting each other.
The superhero world is flooded with male/female
relationships so it was a nice change to see
an LGBT couple featured so prominently on
the show.
Luke Cage and Jessica Jones
These two heroes now both have their own Marvel
Netflix series and from the early hints of
their relationship, it’s going to be a hot
one.
Both physically strong but emotionally weak,
Jessica Jones and Luke Cage find connect through
sex and alcohol.
When Luke and Jessica have their first encounter,
it’s purely a one night stand with no feelings
involved.
But once their friendship progresses, Jessica
finds herself opening up more to him, and
Luke wants to protect her as much as he can.
These two are so powerful and messed up that
end up trying to hurt and save one and other
multiple times in throughout their relationship.
If the shows follow the same storyline as
the comics, we may get to see Luke and Jessica
actually get hitched and have a little super
baby of their own.
Vision and the Scarlet Witch – The Avengers
This couple is the classic case of two people
being very different but for some reason being
attracted to each other all the time.
For starters, Vision is a robot and Scarlet
Witch is absolutely not.
The Vision’s artificial intelligence was
based on the brain of Wonder Man who had a
bit of a thing for the Scarlet Witch himself
back in the day.
In other words, he is somewhat programmed
to be in love with her.
What’s more is that Scarlet’s brother,
Quicksilver, is very much not a fan of his
sister being with a robot and has been very
open with his feelings.
Forbidden love is a common theme in story
telling and that’s probably because it makes
for such hot couples.
Cyclops and Emma Frost
Although Cyclops, A.K.A.
Scott Summers has most famously been paired
with Jean Grey in the comics and the movies,
he has more recently been couples with Emma
Frost.
Jean Grey might be a fiery red head but Summer’s
relationship with the cool and sexy Emma Frost
is actually much hotter.
For starters, Jean Grey often dies and leaves
Scott alone and there is also the ongoing
complication of the love triangle including
Wolverine.
The relationship between Emma Frost and Cyclops
is a more fun and undeniably sexy even though
she is somewhat of a lunatic.
January Jones didn’t do a very good job
with the character in the 2011 film, but hopefully
she’s not gone for good!
Wonder Woman and Steve Trevor
When you are talking about hot superheroes,
Gal Gadot’s Wonder Woman has to be at the
top of the list.
Not only is she absolutely stunning to look
at, but she is a total badass with what looks
to be a great solo movie on the way.
One aspect of the movie that fans don’t
know too much about yet is her relationship
with Steve Trevor, played by Chris Pine.
The trailers haven’t given too much detail,
but it looks like their relationship will
be very important and very hot.
When you have two great looking movie stars
like that paired together, all you can hope
for is great on screen chemistry that you
can sit back and enjoy.
Robin/Nightwing and Starfire — The Teen
Titans
This romance began in Teen Titans Issue #2
when these two overly-hormonal teens met while
Nightwing (then Robin, the Boy Wonder) was
lying flat on his back, and Starfire, the
golden-skinned alien beauty sucking on his
face like it was a scuba mouthpiece.
In later comics it was revealed that she was
actually absorbing his language through physical
contact, and this was the most enjoyable way
to do it, for the both of them.
When people first read this comic it may have
taken them by surprise and made them begin
to question whether or not this is really
how love works.
While we don’t suggest random face sucking,
we will just have to call this hot relationship
a tale of love at first sight.
Harley Quinn and Deadshot
Wait, don’t you mean Harley Quinn and The
Joker?
Well although that couple could be considered
hot (however dysfunctional it may be) it is
definitely one that most people already know
about.
What fans might not know is that Harley and
Deadshot have actually been romantically involved
in the comics for years through little flings
and flirtatious encounters.
News has surfaced that there was actually
plans to set this romance up in the Suicide
Squad movie, but the plans were finally scrapped.
We think this would have been awesome to see
as Will Smith and Margot Robbie were the best
parts of that movie and they have already
shown off their on screen chemistry in the
con artist film, Focus.
So there’s our list of ten super hot superhero
and villain couples that you may not have
known about!
Which one of these is your favorite?
Who do you think is the hottest superhero
of all time?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more fun videos – like this one!